[Music]
for those of you who are in from out of
town or out of country target is a
nationwide discount retailer with
approximately eighteen hundred and forty
five stores three hundred and fifty
thousand team members headquarter
locations in Minneapolis Minnesota in
the San Francisco Bay Area and several
other areas across the country we want
to take a moment and invite you now to
join us at the target open house which
is our I Oh teen smart home showcase
located in the Metreon on the corner of
4th and Mission right here in San
Francisco drop by say hi and if you are
not familiar again with what Target or
Target does our e-commerce website
target.com receives a not insignificant
amount of traffic every month it's the
fourth most visited retail website in
the United States but our retail
presence our dot-com website is just one
of our digital initiatives and part of
our strategy our flagship mobile app
allows you to easily purchase products
from your mobile phone convenient
features like a map the product you're
looking for of where you can find it and
store scan your thing before you buy it
cartwheel offers you discounts with your
red card to quickly check out get on
with your busy life new features like
drive up and shipped provide the
convenience of having you purchase your
purchases brought right out to your car
or delivered straight to your door and
now that we are through with the awkward
sales and marketing presentation you
should recognize that target is
essentially retail that is powered by
technology and what we want to do is
talk to you a little bit about what our
technology is and how we use it a target
take a glance at our agenda today we'll
be talking upfront about what we want
you to get out of everything how we use
target with the Google cloud our journey
thus far and some of our journey into
the future the challenges that we ran
into our expansion into Google for I'm
sorry further into
we'll struggles that we're still having
having and where we're looking at for
the future so as we talk through all of
these things there are a few items that
I want you that Rachel wants you to
watch for these top-level takeaways
please
number one organizing your resources at
Google is well can't be understated how
important it is in order to align those
to how you want to manage cost for
example you might be tempted to use a
single project within which to store all
of your applications or run all of your
applications that may work for you if
you're a small mom-and-pop shop or even
an enterprise customer but we found that
it doesn't work for us because we can't
easily split resources to align with how
we want to manage that cost how you
organize your resources your org your
folders your projects your applications
the project the products inside of those
projects has an enormous impact on how
you look at your bill number two
organize all of these resources to
leverage fingerprints where at all
possible those fingerprints should align
to how you want to manage cost
fingerprints are going to survive the
test of time as your organization
changes as ownership of an application
changes as code means for your projects
change and 3 please don't listen to
everything Google marketing has to say
about how they want you to use a product
for steady for example is pitched as a
security tool but we're using it to
enforce the data integrity for our
application fingerprints all right in
order to start driving home some of
these concepts it's gonna help I think
to know why we think they're important
so maybe even important enough for a 50
minute talk hmm find out and that's
going to require just a little bit of
setup target has as I just mentioned
almost 2,000 stores distribution centers
warehouses data centers etc nationwide
and there are select aspects at every
single one of those locations such that
that location good could be considered a
quote-unquote cloud environment across
the board we have infrastructure there
we have platforms there we have
applications there and due to the
geographic distribution and the
sometimes limited connectivity based on
where those locations are each store
each site I should say is treated as a
standalone isolated cloud environment
you could call them for lack of a better
word mini clouds right we also have our
own data centers with similar resources
there's just a lot more of them so maybe
those are not so many clouds not quite
mega clouds and then since we're giving
this talk it should be pretty obvious
and should surprise no one that we also
use public cloud providers such as
Google's cloud all right we'll call them
and make a cloud that's fine to us and
this is the most important part that I
can get across in this slide we want to
treat all of these resources the exact
same way
eeep Laura bassoon um if I can write
regardless of the disparity in the
infrastructure we want apps runnable
everywhere in the same exact way the
target way not the stores way not the
distribution center way not Google's way
but the target way the infrastructure is
all managed slightly differently and
that means that we need some sort of
platform in the middle there between the
infrastructure and the applications in
order to be truly ubiquitous so we wrote
a thing and we call it the target
application platform or tap the idea
simple given every possible compute
location that target uses the experience
of deploying an application to any of
those locations should be exactly the
same now if you were at the keynote this
morning
you heard something from Google called
similar called and folks I think I'm
saying that right I
we only heard it once or twice this
morning and tap I want you to know we
want you to know just hit its one-year
anniversary 4 days ago and pretty much
kind of does the same exact things okay
the intricacies of taps design how we
got there why we did it those are all
the contents of another presentation and
that youtube link should you want to
take a picture or take a look at the
slide deck later we'll take you to last
year's presentation on the design of tap
that we gave at Google next 18 in July
or if you have time this evening you can
attend dev to 1:7 given by some of my
colleagues tonight at 5:00 p.m.
all right the bottom line regardless is
that we have clouds everywhere and we
try to manage and want to manage what
runs they're all in the same exact way
so what does that mean for he'll target
uses Google cloud all right we have two
primary goals in leveraging any cloud
provider the first we want to put the
things that impact our guests our
customers that's our term for guests if
you're not familiar with this parlance
as close to the guests as possible and
regardless of the kinds of workloads
that we could run they're the things
that make the most sense at any public
cloud provider our target com our mobile
apps the things that you when you walk
into a store experience right then and
there and the second thing is that we
want to do it in the most cost effective
way possible and that kind of becomes a
tricky situation and the point of the
talk scale public cloud providers all
scale that comes for free Google does it
better than everybody else I'm biased
anyway but even if we weren't using tap
or any other sort of target custom-built
tool to deploy our workloads out to
Google putting stuff out at a cloud
provider it's dead easy right but making
sure that we're using it in the most
effective way possible so much harder
than we thought so much harder than we
thought
you probably
in fact I'm just gonna pause from the
script here who who thinks that it's
hard to track how you're using your
applications out of Google by show ads
right okay take 20% now 10% that's all
right boy that makes me want to ask why
everybody else is here even if we
weren't doing that it's super hard so
why why is it hard some of that is based
on the choices we've made and some of
that is frankly based on the structure
of how Google does things of how we've
chosen to use Google and of how Google
allows themselves to be used we'll talk
about both so billing is a hot topic at
Google right we're talking about money
here and it gets a lot of visibility so
it gets a lot of questions with it
questions from seniors leadership to our
finance teams all of the infrastructure
teams that deploy manage services on
Google cloud and then all the way down
to the application teams that deploy
their apps on Google cloud as well so we
can kind of break these questions into
two different categories reactive right
so I get the bill and I'm like holy crap
why is this so big what am i spending my
money on where are these services coming
from right storage compute databases
logging or something else and then
there's proactive right how do I know if
this is a good number if is it too high
or is it too low or is this just bad
right how do I be more effective and
what I deploy on Google cloud how do I
understand how to be better or how do I
understand how to lower this number and
so there's one question that I want you
to think about every time we talk about
something up here every time you're
going to make a decision on a tool or a
service and that is really how do I
provide the most information that teams
can use in order to make better
decisions and then hit the next slide
here yep so we're gonna talk a lot about
things that we've done in the past today
things that we're currently doing and
then things that we want to do in the
future and I'm gonna pause a few times
and I'm going to ask this question and
based off of the answer that's how we're
gonna decide on what we're gonna do all
right so there's a long journey to put
stuff out at the cloud the larger the
enterprise likely sometimes longer the
journey is but whenever you start on any
journey experience your own personal
experience is going to tell you that
there are things that
you can be pretty sure you're going to
run into along the way right some of
those things you know exactly what to do
about it before you even get there you
know you'll just have to deal with the
front desk clerk at the hotel and you
can't change their attitude and life is
just gonna suck for those first few
seconds so your guy they're gonna just
have to deal with it climb over that
hurdle or go around it somehow right we
can't control the weather but we can
certainly take a look at the forecast
and dress appropriately or bring an
umbrella but there are also things on
any journey that trip you up along the
way and knock you flat on your face when
you're not expecting them to happen when
targets first started moving workloads
into Google we did not do it in a Big
Bang kind of way
it was piecemeal a little bit at a time
we were inching our way in while
migrating out of another cloud provider
we knew some of what we were walking
into and we very unknowing very much
unknowingly brought a whole ton of
baggage with us billing was absolutely
not a primary thought but it was there
right we want to know we want to be able
to control it but it wasn't a primitive
it wasn't considered something that was
key when we started this journey so this
piecemeal method unfortunately led us to
making some decisions and choices that
made sense at the time that later turned
into the kinds of things that you trip
over because you didn't see it in the
path and makes you fall flat on your
face and that some of those things made
sense at the previous provider like a
singular project made sense there
doesn't make sense here to us at Google
all of a sudden we were thrust into a
situation where we had to give better
information to our developers and we
weren't well equipped to do it
everything's a journey though right
you've got missteps you've got back
tracks you've got bridge buildings par
for the course so let's talk about some
of the things we saw before we ever
started this migration let's call them
big rocks these are the things you know
you're gonna run into
at Target we're absolutely not going to
be able to change the organizational
structure of our company from the ground
up to suit what is possible at a given
cloud provider so we need a way to
identify a resource and have that
reportable at every level of the orc
that rock we kind of chose to ignore
going in even though we knew it was
there we didn't treat it as a primitive
don't make that meant don't make that
same choice that we made please
secondarily while most companies
actually split up their bill and pass
that along to various parts of their
organization either for direct payment
or internal transfer of funds target
takes that bill splits it up and shows
every level of our organization what
they've spent but we don't expect any
payment in return for that one part of
the org is responsible for paying all
infrastructure costs associated with
that provider and that part alone is
responsible for the cost control
associated with that bill so we all
share responsibility in summary here we
all share responsibility in contributing
to that bill but only one party is
accountable to its management that's
that can be a problem imagine you're an
application team and you're sitting
there and people are telling you spend
less why do you care you are neither
accountable it doesn't impact you
financially it potentially impacts you
technologically to change the way that
you're running your application why do
you care we'll talk more about that a
little bit later but just keep in mind
that we have no carrot or stick to
change a team's decisions about how they
use their resources at Google and lastly
that last bullet point bring your own
kubernetes we knew from the very very
beginning that we would not be using gke
but bringing our own kubernetes clusters
to Google Cloud
if you're familiar with kubernetes
either older versions of gke or some of
the more recent versions of kubernetes
native you know that the idea of shared
resources is great from a compute
efficiency point of view but tracking
who used what when can be kind of hard
so we knew upfront we were going to need
a way to apportion our kubernetes VM
bill such that we knew how a namespace
was being used in a relatively accurate
way all right so these are the things
that weren't going to change when we
moved our workloads to Google we still
have to know how we're going to climb
over these rocks and achieve what we
want to achieve it turns out that every
big cloud provider also has their own
big rocks that you absolutely can't
change at Google one of those is labels
remember we want the holy grail of
enabling these teams to make their own
better decisions
labeling very popular way not new to add
more meta information to your resources
and they even end up in billing exports
which if you spend a lot of time in them
is so fantastic you've got attributions
to send back life is great but there are
products like stack driver logging that
records information coming in from
resources like HTTP load balancers that
can be labeled but the resulting logs
from those resources cannot be
apportioned even though they have their
own cost associated with them for
example in the screenshot cloud HTTP
load balancers there is in that
particular resource the log that is load
balancer logs cannot be labeled but
remember we also have one project up
front all of our applications are
sharing this log source how do I find
out that application a is largely
responsible for 50 or more percent of
all of the costs going in there and give
that team accurate show back
help them manage themselves right
remember we started with that single
project and we just kept moving new
applications in so the more apps we had
the harder it became and now let's talk
about some of the tripping stones all
right I think that they came in three
different kinds of categories first
there are things that we knew we'd be
creating tech debt for but if we did it
a certain way but we did it anyway
thinking to ourselves we'll deal with it
later okay now I want to show a hands
who does that all the time thank you
everybody thank you you are lying if you
do not raise your hand that's fine the
second category is that we couldn't do
it the way that we assumed we could
because of either a misunderstanding or
some reason or another about our
interpretation of the docs or the way
the docs were written or who knows what
and the third category is that we didn't
know we could do it or we didn't know
that we had to do it in order to get
that piece of information okay so let's
talk about some of those items at our
previous cloud provider for example we
had established a naming convention such
that an app and component combo would
uniquely identify the application
utilizing a resource so that even would
even address certain security startup
problems like let's make sure that if
you are not a registered application or
registered component we're not going to
allow you to read these secrets out of
our platform we're not going to allow
you to read these key value pairs we're
not going to allow you to register your
services and because oh let actually let
me back up just one moment and give an
example think about application and
component think about price as an
application and within price we might
have an API we might have a Redis
component of these things they all roll
up to this price application but
everything's got their own component
this is legacy this is previous cloud
provider but did you know that
application teams love code names for
what they write okay at least I see some
smiles
is good and what happens when those code
names change what happens when a new
leader comes in and says I don't want to
own that product anymore give it to
so-and-so
all of a sudden the application still
exists the product still exists the
components may change but it no longer
rolls up to the same portion of the
organization and that's not good that's
not good for tracking cost over time the
first apps that we put out at Google
only used compute and network resources
that's important to know because I maybe
this is partly defensive to say we kind
of knew what might happen but that's all
right there was no big query there was
no stackdriver there was no anything
except compute and network because
remember we wanted an agnostic way to be
able to use those primitives that every
public cloud provider offered in order
to have our platform be agnostic and
deployable to any location putting
ourselves into a single project totally
made sense at the time but how do you
divvy up those things all right here so
some of the challenges that we face this
is just a basic output of our our
billing data flow looks like and it
should look pretty similar right you go
into the cloud console into the billing
section and you hit export my data it
all goes into a Google cloud storage
bucket and then I get sent into bigquery
from there we created a handful of views
that we could actually visualize this
data in a different tool and the two
tools that we primarily used for data
studio and grow fana and just for
reference data studio is a Google
product but it is not a Google cloud
product however it is very easy to
integrate the data between the two and
then graph on ax is just another
visualization tool that target uses as
part of our measurement platform so this
is what the billing data file looks like
two big caveats that I want to call out
is that first our teams don't have
access to actually go into the cloud
console they don't have those i.m
permissions we use other tools to
actually deploy such a spinnaker or for
teams that are deploying containers you
can just directly from the command line
so that kind of posed a problem when we
wanted to use labels right because
labels was an option but it wasn't
enforced it wasn't regulated so
therefore teams just didn't do it so
that was the first challenge that we
really needed to figure out is how
we go through and apply those labels
when teams aren't doing it themselves so
our short-term solution was to write a
script that retroactively Lee goes in a
couple times a day and looks at all the
new instances that are created grabs the
instance name and then applies that name
as a label under a key value pair so we
we had the key of something like Finance
tag or application and then the actual
value of that would be the actual
instance name so first caveat second
caveat is I'm forgetting some of my
notes here
um let's move on so this is an example
of the data studio dashboard that we had
initially created as you can see this is
the price application that Ron mentioned
a little bit ago and you can see the
components here API Redis solar
Cassandra the actual design is not what
what I really want to talk about it's
not the meat of this presentation how we
filter how we group everything together
is what is important here so we use a
feature that is within data studio
itself called filtering and since it is
not coming from bigquery all of these
filters that we apply are all manual so
for each application team that's still
playing into google cloud we've created
a new dashboard for them we created a
new filter for them and so as you can
imagine as our teams grow as the
applications girl in google it gets
really cumbersome because for the
initial migration the 40 or so
applications that we had it was more of
like a Mentalist and Ron and I his mine
alright we know the price application
team we know who owns it at a broader
level but when you start having teams
that change ownership or they start
changing code names and for reference
everybody loves to put the word red and
every of the code name is we have so
you've got 20 Reds somewhere um it's
really cumbersome that gets really
manual it's something that can't scale
with all of our apps now another problem
this is just for teams that are directly
deploying on virtual machines Ron
mentioned that we brought our own
kubernetes clusters and roughly about
half of the compute that we use are
actually kubernetes clusters and those
kubernetes clusters are essentially
virtual machines in compute engine right
so that label that's getting applied to
them they're all getting tagged as
kubernetes master kubernetes node and
when we need to actually go down and
break down that usage and see who's
using what something that we can't do
with data studio so that leads us to
a different dashboard now this is a tool
called Cortana which I mentioned before
is part of targets measurement stack and
so what we ended up doing is writing an
API that goes in and grabs the total
number of CPU and memory requests per
namespace and a science of relative cost
compared to the total number of CPU and
memory requests per cluster and we got
the total cost of the cluster from those
labels that we were using since it's
still getting tagged here now this
dashboard and the one that I just had
before roughly showed the same thing
right the breakdown per application over
a period of time and per environment
we've got both their tests production
tests project and production project as
well now what if you're an application
team and you're deploying both
containers and virtual machines one of
the questions that I always got was can
you just show me one number like I don't
want to have to go to two different
places like I know it's super simple
right
and so we did the most high-tech thing
we could think of and we sent all of
this data into an Excel spreadsheet on a
manual basis on a weekly basis and just
so you know I still get asked for the
spreadsheet today and this is we know we
did this two years ago
so just to recap all of our virtual
machines that were getting deployed for
getting tagged with labels and that was
going into data studio all of our
kubernetes deployments our container
deployments were getting tagged using
that API and breaking down by namespace
and that was going into another
visualization tool called frana
and since we split the two up we had to
marry him back together in this excel
spreadsheet that alone is a number of
problems that I don't even want to get
into and I'm sure you can guess what
those are
but at this point we're just tagging
compute right I mean granted compute is
a huge percentage of our bill like 80 or
90 percent at this point but we're
largely ignoring every other cost I mean
we had a handful of cloud storage
buckets we had a handful of cloud sequel
instances and for both of those cases
those things can be labeled and tagged
and we weren't we were just ignoring I'm
be labeled it is like an overhead cost
to moved on but then we had all these
other things too like the stack driver
monitoring and then certain networking
costs that can't be tied back to an
instance and then one last problem that
this is just a test project in a
production project granted they were the
two largest projects within our entire
org but we had a handful of other
projects that were proof of concepts or
sting reasons that we're also ignoring
so this initial migration into Google
cloud again like I said it was about 40
or so applications we were tagging most
of what we could but let's think back to
that first question that I asked
everybody right does this provide
information that teams can use in order
to make better decisions can I look at
one of these dashboards and say I know
that's a good number I know that's bad
or I know that's too high or I know
where my waist is and the answers still
no right I want to mention briefly
something that Rachel mentioned and
that's all of the unalaq
came out of our first pass she said that
they they have a tendency to just kind
of be dismissed or assigned to the
platform team incorrectly namely our
teams such that it looks like we are ten
percent of our entire total bill when in
fact we're probably 1 percent or less we
just have everything that isn't
allocable all right anyway thus far in
our journey target had chosen to run
only non commerce workloads related to
target comm at Google some of that was
in support of mobile some not these
workloads are all about the public
information that's available on our
website you go to the website you browse
you see a price you see an item those
are API endpoints that is not secret
there's not a ton of security that we
need to put out there around those kinds
of controls but that security relatively
simple in comparison to what we were
about to undertake so in July of 2018 we
started to migrate our commerce
workloads to Google cloud and that of
course came with one huge new Big Rock
regulatory compliance anybody okay we've
got yes this is a problem definitely
from security so we knew we needed to
look at our organ at organizing our
resources a little bit better to be able
to manage that regulatory compliance
easier and we had a chance to apply at
least some of what we had done
to fix some of those pesky little
tripping stones that we had tripped on
project naming conventions application
code names and more so let's take a look
get out your phones this is the one that
you you want to take a picture of right
and the second or third to last slide as
well this is from our colleagues that
are presenting networking 200 a year in
GCP networking unfortunately that talk
is happening right now please don't get
up and leave in another room but similar
to the talk that is happening right now
they same the same colleagues are giving
a talk on called architecture 2:08
70 days PCI compliance to production
with them with a hybrid cloud that's
right 70 business days using this design
to get all of our commerce workloads out
there and one of our presenters are
sitting here in the front row with a big
wide smile going all right let's talk
about some of the lessons here for our
purposes today I want to be able to call
out some huge benefits of this design
that translate into better tracking
better billing costs first we learned
that leveraging every available
capability of a shared V PC is a
no-brainer one of those capabilities is
putting resources in one project within
an organization but allowing
communication to happen between the
projects using a shared or shared subnet
for example define all the subnets in
one area but define the actual resources
in each of the compute projects or in
their own project should refer to the
notes specifically I say you know the
subnets there and the compute engine
resources in their own project so what
does this do now when a team spins up a
compute resource it's in a project
assigned to that team and only that team
yay but Rachel's going to talk in a
little bit about how that's still a
problem number two platform components
that were previously getting all of the
unallocated just like every application
that's out there
so that's good and we get project level
I am all of a sudden that we didn't have
before that we had to build our own
security around and was just nasty third
app teams can consume now Google
specific services and their usage gets
attached directly to that project that's
allocable to that team it doesn't matter
that they're using something that can't
be tagged anymore right maybe everything
in the project belongs to them but maybe
it still matters that we can't tag it
for quota management oh wow I'm sure our
partners at Google were very very happy
to stop getting our phone calls about we
need another two thousand instances
raised in our in our production
environment or give us another ten
thousand this or we need more load
balancers I that knows what but
regardless there is still a problem here
every application team could be putting
more than just their application into a
particular project
Rachael's going to talk about that we
need some sort of better identification
so back to our second highlight from the
one of our second takeaway from the top
of the slide deck lowest common
denominator so introducing the
configuration item ID hey ITIL users
everybody life is great it's an eight
digit unique number across all of
targets business units and you remember
at the beginning when we were talking
about tap the goal of tab is to deploy
things the target way across our fleet
it is not the store's way not the Google
Cloud Way the target way C is a target
identifier lovely they are our lowest
common denominator and what if we could
apply them to everything at Google great
idea right accepts it's not a new idea a
lot of you in the room are going yeah
yeah we do this already this is fine no
big deal but our additional challenge is
if an application team has no financial
responsibility to tag their stuff or
voluntarily tag their resources how do
we leverage tech to do it for us
how do we enforce or at least manage the
data consistency how can we ensure
complete coverage of all of those
resources at Google hello cloud
functions again maybe not a new idea we
asked our teams to label their resources
but if they mess it up if they screw it
up that's okay we have cloud functions
in place for the launch of every compute
resource that allows for the sanitation
and standardization of the configuration
item data if teams don't supply a CI at
all that's okay what do we do well if we
really care to we could have that cloud
function prevent that instance from
starting up and just say our security
teams really like this idea by the way
but since it's really about making infra
easy for app teams to consume that
seemed a little extreme so how do we
track this hello for setting it's
pitched as a security tool but at its
base if you're not familiar with it it's
just about finding deviations from a
desired standard we run reports to
identify things that can have labels but
don't things that have a misconstrued
label that indicate that we need to have
better logic inside of our functions
notification is manual for now but
there's nothing stopping us from
spending some time and throwing out
taking our best guess at who actually
owns that application and automating a
report to be sent back out to them we
also have some pretty crazy ideas about
making that back-end more robust and
automated that involved pub/sub that
involves stackdriver monitoring that
involved cloud tasks and even machine
learning to help us be even smarter
about these decisions while you're here
this week keep a close eye on alphas
betas ga is being announced
I've been scrubbed from talking about
the programs that we use but there are
exciting things on the horizon that will
make some of the challenges that we're
talking about and mentioned in the last
few slides all of a sudden very very
easy already we've got these
configuration items that were now
applying to everything in Google Cloud
Ron and I are thrilled because that
means the end of all that manual
filtering that we had to do in data
studio and instead you see a dashboard
like this where at the top you can drop
down and choose your specific
configuration item or perhaps a cluster
of configuration items that apply to
your application you can also drop down
and select your specific project that
you want to see and you can see all of
the data that you could see before in
this case for showing compute it's also
tagging at cloud storage it's tagging
cloud sequel everything that can be
tagged is getting tagged yeah yeah right
no that's not what happened so some
teams took our advice and they started
tagging different components with each
different CI or configuration item other
teams just kept on doing what they were
doing before and they used the same
configuration item across all of the
components in their application other
teams who managed multiple applications
used one configuration item across
multiple applications so this didn't
work right we wanted to be able to break
down our cost even further we wanted to
be able to allocate where the spending
was coming down even further but that
didn't really happen and again we still
don't really have a way of providing
real-time increases in decreases as
teams make updates to their
infrastructure which is something that
was been on the back of our mind
something we wanted to do but we still
hadn't quite figured out so we kept our
old dashboards we kept all of the manual
filtering even after we kept growing our
footprint at Google I mean we started
with those additional 40 apps and we've
grown beyond that now and we still have
these manual filters although I guess
the nice thing is that once you build
them you're done right you don't have to
go in and change them or anything like
that hopefully and assuming teams don't
change their names or ownerships but if
you look at this dashboard it's slightly
different than the one that I showed you
before and that's because we edited our
filters just slightly so we showed
beyond application - component at this
point we're showing different versions
of components you can see here for price
their API they've got a version 1 and
version 2 you can also see that they're
in multiple regions so we've got
breakdowns by region as well and
essentially these are the instance
groups that are getting a deployed right
I mean initially we were grabbing the
instance name and that's where that
label comes from but at this point were
able to group by instance group now and
most of our apps use instance groups to
deploy rather than just deploying a
single instance at a time
can you talk about why that's important
why all of this is if a team wants
better information to make better to sit
more information to make better
decisions yeah how are they ever going
to know that version 2 of an application
is performing better and using less
money than version 1 if we don't have
this and that's what these dashboards
did right so you can see that they've
got multiple versions deployed and
they're the versions might be different
right they make an update Center code
they make a different modification or
something and they redeploy and we can
monitor now we can see the changes we
can see the disparities between the two
and they can decide which one's better
so where does that leave us right let's
think back to that initial question does
this provide enough information that
teams can use to make those better
decisions the answers still no
unfortunately right we're not providing
enough information right it seems like
costs data just isn't cutting it at this
point and so as we looked to expanding
these dashboards beyond Google cloud
right we wanted to increment or
integrate all of our other platforms as
well potentially all of our managed
services we really had to figure out why
the answer to that question kept being
known and that's where we come up with
different kinds of information
specifically capacity and efficiency so
we're going through we're tagging all of
this other information right we're
looking at capacity the total number of
VMs that I've got deployed and we're
looking at efficiency right so of those
100 VM that I might have just deployed
like what am I actually using my 5%
utilization of my at 10% right and those
those numbers are what we can start
conversations with and obviously you're
all familiar like for capacity like it
I'm close to relate it to cost you
because I spin up 100 VMs that's my
total capacity that's total allocated
number of resources that I've got and I
pay for that right I pay for what I've
spun up and I don't pay for what I
actually use of that so it's really
important when we're talking about you
know managing costs and eliminate an
operating cost and everything like that
because that starts that conversation
with those act teams so that we can make
them more not reliable but make them
more cognizant of what their spending is
and again like I said we really wanted
to expand our cost dashboards across all
of our platforms and so now by combining
the three kinds of information we can
and we can also target our managed
services as well and so when I say
managed services we've got a couple
different infrastructure teams that
provide services for application teams
to you such as
database tools or measurement tools and
historically every database cost was
attributed back to the database team
even though a bunch of application teams
were using those databases and so now we
can do what this information is actually
tie it back to the application team
that's using it so where does that leave
us going forward this is a pretty new
initiative at Target and something that
we're still building out but essentially
what we want to do is capture a location
utilization and cost data altogether
right all of its a ton of data and at
the deepest level that we can so for
some of our platforms it's all the way
down to an individual host or server
others not so much just really depends
on the platform but we're gonna export
that data we're gonna start publishing
it so that teams can actually see it but
before it was just for infrastructure
teams right I could go in and see what
my platform like the utilization of it
but I didn't share that with the
application teams using my platform and
so that was really a change of a change
of how we did things so we're exporting
all this data either via Kafka topics or
an API we're still kind of understanding
and identifying what the best practice
is for a long term especially as some of
our platforms are a little bit more
modern and then some of them are a
little bit legacy at our data center so
we really just need to figure out what
the best way is and then we're ingesting
all of that data in a single place and
it's all getting aggregated on our Big
Data platform which does live in our
data centers we're working with our data
science teams to build a couple of views
so that we're not sending all of that
data somewhere else right we're just
sending what we need and we're
displaying it on a single dashboard that
you can export that data into a CSV if
you need it to get that fine level
detail but essentially this dashboard if
I were an application team I can go and
say here's my configuration item or
here's my application and I can see
everywhere that it's deployed I can see
the total allocated resources that I've
got for that configuration item or for
my component for my app I can see the
actual CPU and memory utilization of
that and then I can see if we can
provide it attributable cost you're
familiar it's really hard to determine
specific costs for apps that are
deployed in data centers it's really
easy for Google because I get a bill
every month but for our data centers
it's not the case so favorite question
does this provide information can a team
go into this dashboard see information
and make a decision based off of that
and finally we think the answer is yes
we hope so again like I said we're still
kind of building out this whole
dashboard and what it looks like
but we have been sending it out to teams
and it's been providing a lot of great
results already and it really helps us
start those conversations with the teams
that might be over subscribing or they
might be over allocating resources to
themselves and they're not using it and
so it's just a way for us to be a little
bit better an efficient seeing capacity
so just to recap we talked about how we
organize things and why I didn't work
for us and then we talked about how we
did it differently right and don't want
you to be afraid of changing the way
that things were assuming you can we
talked about the common denominator
that's configuration item it didn't work
for us great in Google cloud but it's
something that was a standard across
target and so if you were to go on a
requests new resources for something in
our data centers like you are required
to enter in that configuration item that
is a standard practice across all of our
platforms now so teams know what it is
they know they're expecting you they
know they need to do it and then the
products for setting and cloud functions
they're not used for billing they
weren't marketed for billing but we're
using for that anyways because we're
making it work for what we needed it to
do ubiquitous computing bit cuentas
billing platforms yes I mentioned I
mentioned the target application or cap
rate the idea was that regardless of
where you're deploying our application
you go to one spot and everything you
need is right there that's the same
approach that we wanted to take with
billing to write just you go you go to
one spot everything is there that you
need you don't need anything else and
with that we just love to thank you
thank you exciting yeah thanks
[Applause]
[Music]